oh et kde bonsoir je dis
sac à dos
car vous êtes ici ce soir pour le
premier film d'olivier ce soir je dors
chez toi olivier baroux et là monsieur
monsieur olivier baroux c'est bizarre
mais il faut citer d'un film paul di
resta film de science-fiction oui
puisque le beau gosse dont est amoureuse
la sublimer la vérité c'est jean paul
roux non c'est tout bêtement un probable
mais bon voilà
comédie romantique donc ce soir je dors
chez toi avec mélanie doutey
sublimissime tue son numéro portable sur
jean paul rouve donc kad merad ont
précisé que j'ai un blouson c'est parce
que j'ai une chemise qui utilisent les
acheteurs exceptions près ce que tu
voies romaines mentaux
au delà de la vache folle a acheté à
prague voilà une autre actualité
incroyable vous allez passer deux jours
avec sophie davant
ah oui une grille parra du téléthon elle
est l étang salé il va bien sûr qu'ils
paraissent vraiment hommage en tout cas
il m'a donné à moi je vous dis à chaque
fois vous toucherez les sainte sophie
davant je donnerais d'accord
combien je peux donner jusqu'à 1000
euros à chaque fois vous toucher les
seins de sophie davant bureau
va envoyer soixante douze bouteilles de
vin révèle couton veyrac a touché les
nichons mon peuple non je pouvais pas
faire ça s'est désolé si tu veux aussi
avec elle si si ben non pas lui qui peut
ruiner thierry ardisson
ses 10000
guy forget l'écart comme disait
desproges donner au téléthon c'est
toujours ça que les restos du coeur ne
rompt pas
qui
vous connaissez le principe bouby tisser
des rumeurs ou pas des rumeurs d'accord
vous êtes prêt monsieur cadre est tout à
fait monsieur bao
bernard kouchner aurait enregistré un
disque de rap en allemand vraiment bravo
bravo lyon regarde
[Musique]
bernard kouchner aux points 1,20 à l'eau
quels artistes noirs au bataclan ensuite
en tournée dans toute la france
c'est vrai il adore chanter venez
chanter ils chantent le nouveau sextoys
anglais à la mode qui garantirait un
orgasme
en 10 secondes en 10 secondes en 10
secondes se brancherait sur l'aspirateur
sur l'aspirateur tu vas jouer
la fibre savez bien vous inspire pas
moins tu as fait pour les attentions ben
laden aurait été aperçu dimanche dernier
chez ikea en train de choisir un canapé
de la paroisse
[Musique]
pourquoi pas puisqu'on sait partie des
envies d'aller casser du bois on sait
pas où il est dans un nouvel épisode de
star wars intitulé vador in love dark
vador tomberait amoureux d'une darkpink
le bon
[Musique]
c'est une famille en fait de la bbc
c'est très bien fait ça vous intéressez
ça le chercheur qui va trouver le
traitement contre la maladie d'alzheimer
aurait oublié la formule exacte du
traitement
aux états unis paris hilton aurait
menacé de faire un enfant
paris -
dont closer
afin de rendre hommage à l'oeuvre de son
père pierre pasqua aurait été condamné à
un an de prison ferme
à frédéric beigbeder serait prêt à
arrêter la cocaïne pour faire pression
sur le gouvernement colombien ça s'est
couvert de faire c'est tout
[Applaudissements]
nikos aliagas t'aurais pas une formation
de vendeur de kebab murray une maîtrise
de littérature à la sorbonne c'est
vraiment
par superstition nikos aliagas porterait
le même ce clip pour chaque prime de la
star academy depuis sept ans
gilbert montagné aurait conduit une
voiture à plus de 160 km heure c'est
vrai
ces chaînes
oui
sous l'équateur durée
entre
l'année
zina renseigner
annonce une probable collision de la mer
noire george bush aurait déclaré ça se
verra pas
non mais il a déclaré je ne sais pas où
est la merde
afin de préparer au mieux la sortie du
beaujolais nouveau christine bravo
aurait pris une semaine de congés payés
à la main si elle est en pleine avant
elle est charmante et ça va vraiment
très sûr que c'est la même je pense que
c'est la même je trouve qu'elle est à
d'europe nicolas sarkozy aurait demandé
à bernard kouchner avait pas des
français emprisonnés aux seychelles
histoire d'y passer le week-end prochain
les premiers mots de georges bush en
revoyant nicolas sarkozy aurait été mais
alors on est pris pour un con peu de
femmes que tu es malade
il restera en vie autant de poilus de la
guerre de 14 que deux beatles oui c'est
vrai de bursa comme quoi c'est plus
dangereux d'être beatles que notre point
de vue
ouais bah ouais
ok d'accord c'est la guerre
bienvenue tu as dit henri leconte ferait
partie de la liste de patrick balkany
pour les municipales de levallois oui
merde en cas de défaite aux municipales
de levallois henri leconte aurait déjà
prévu de dire qu'il était blessé au
genou
selon emmanuel de brantes l'api paul la
plus mal élevés de france serait
véronique genest selon lui peut-être sur
voilà à cette annonce véronique genest
aurait déclaré je ne suis pas prélever
qu'est ce qui lui prend à ce fils de
[ __ ] d'enculés
[Musique]
et maintenant mesdames messieurs
1re et à monsieur olivier dard moi
j'imagine un film d'olivier baroux
jean-michel semoule qui tombe amoureux
de jacqueline gastro et une musique de
manuel
ne va pas du tout pas du tout c'est une
comédie romantique très réservé à
l'angle est très fleur bleue très prête
moi ta main ça s'appelle ce soir je dors
chez toi avec mélanie doutey sublime
mélanie doutey mélanie j'te kiffe
kad merad mesdames messieurs l'ineffable
caméra pour son 10e film
événement une catégorie film de kad
merad pascal actuellement guimond faire
une catégorie à part césar et tu auras
donc le césar du film de kad merad
c'était un grand du cinéma maintenant
alors le truc en fait c'est qu'au lieu
de finir ensemble comme dans toutes les
communes et romantique celle comédie
romantique un mec rencontre une fille
des tests à la fin ils vont ils pas
ensemble c'est comme ça depuis le banc
et là pas du tout cas quelle histoire
c'est qu'au départ ils vont vendre
ensemble et en fait ils se séparent en
fait c'est ça c'est ça l'histoire il a
peur de l'amour dont il se dit si je
suis avec elle parce que je suis
tellement blaireau je vais la perte
c'est sûr va partir donc il se dit on va
inventer un truc c'est le célibat à deux
chacun chez soi et on vivra heureusement
ça marche pas et c'est débile comme un
simple et voilà il sait il va s'enferrer
dans des problèmes il va demander à 4
son meilleur peut devenir vite chez lui
alors qu'eads merad dans ce film donc et
à un ami de deux ans par le groupe yoc
7ème éditeur qui est assez
extraordinaire espèce de bobos et les
douilles jusque là et que steam en
velours fuchsia c'est très jubilatoire à
la semaine c'est vrai que c'est mélanie
doutey qui a exigé que dans le scénario
elle trompe aussi le mec pas exiger elle
me l'a proposé j'ai accepté mais n'ont
pas exigé non les juges avec monsieur
alain je suis quand même parce que lui
il la trompe bon d'accord mais elles
elles veulent tromper aussi c'est bien
les femmes d'aujourd'hui
elles veulent très
douces à
l'intérêt commun c'est qu'ils trouvent
ça normal une chez toi c'est les moeurs
que vous avez voulu
qu'on regrette d'avoir voulu qu'on
n'aurait jamais dû faire 68 bon allez on
va regarder à quoi ça ressemble donc
laetitia c'est la femme de ma vie
une réponse on vit ensemble oui ou non
il faut que je reste ferme et déterminée
oui et merde que j'habite chez toi titia
me pose un ultimatum je suis pas prêt ah
oui et le non tu savais si votre truc
c'est dans les murs et sera bien la
tempe oui donc sinon qu'est-ce que tu
étais modèles de chaque île et ne pas
passer mais il a demandé à l'ex de
l'héberger parce qu'il était un peu
dépressif à
tunis est vrai que il avait la patate
triste tous les battus et dépressif
dépressif
jean-jacques
bonjour je sais sur une bombe là elle me
teste sûr qu'elle a tout compris on y
pleure
[Musique]
tu comprennes une chose si je vis avec
toi je te perds la peau phrase c'est nul
tu es nul c nul tu es nul
et belle comme le jour où elle demande
katé mé mais tu peux pas comprendre
ce soit avec moi dans ton travail avec
ses amis tu sais pas tu engagée elle est
là c'est la mêlée par et c'est la chance
de ta vie tu es vraiment trop con
heureusement que c'est l'amie qui me
parle
je peux pas vivre sans elle apporte une
motion que ce soit et c'est le faire
[Musique]
en libye avant
m
c'est jean paul rault kad merad philippe
lefebvre
moi j'ai dans notre histoire merci j'ai
été annoncé à prague le débat dans notre
histoire c'est que moi j'ai j'ai un peu
j'ai commencé un peu plus à jouer
l'acteur avant que lui il attendre son
tour et c'était pas évident et tout d'un
coup je savais qu il attendait son tour
et il attendait le bon film et
maintenant je vois là je suis très
content parce qu'il fait un film
merveilleux et c'est très agréable
d'être d'être épanouie mois comme acteur
il lui sentir qu'ils épanoui comme règle
ce soir vous nous aimez vraiment c'est
vachement agréable et on est des potes
en plus donc on est
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux